(soft upbeat music)
- I think my idea of how
creativity works in STEM jobs
has changed since I've gone to college.
I used to think that
all the mathematicians
would be locked away in some office
and typing on the computers
or writing down equations by themselves
and coming up with
incredibly beautiful ideas
just by themselves.
But I'm realizing now that I'm in college
that mathematics and creativity,
it's a lot about communication,
and it's a lot about
trying to build off of each other's ideas
and bounce ideas off of each other
and build upon ideas that
have already been made
by people decades ago.
And I think that the facts
that we all come with it,
with our own perspectives,
and different ideas and
different ways of being creative
allows math to advance further,
because we can all
combine our creative ideas
into something bigger.
- We collect data on everything, right?
And so the ability to use that data
in a smart, safe, and efficient way
depends on new applications
of mathematical concepts
to these new and innovative data sets.
As we get to that point,
we'll start to be thinking
outside the box a lot more,
and we'll be a much more
innovative, digital society,
but that can't happen unless
we start trying to be creative,
and not just rely on tried and true.
(soft upbeat music)